sur public sénat bonjour et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo en compagnie cette semaine de
delphine girard bon jour d'halloween
dans l'actualité politique et
parlementaire cette semaine il ya eu le
cafouillage du gouvernement autour des
panneaux avertisseurs de radars faut-il
ou non les enlever réponses
contradictoires de françois fillon et
claude guéant dans la même journée de
mardi
au final la grogne des députés ump n'est
pas retombé et l'automobiliste lui n'a
pas vraiment conclut ce qui l'attend
maintenant sur la route réunion du g8 à
deauville barack obama et nicolas
sarkozy ont souligné leurs convergences
sur les grands dossiers libye syrie aide
aux pays arabes
dans les couloirs on a aussi beaucoup
parlé de la candidature de christine
lagarde à la tête du fmi qui a aussi
reçu le soutien des américains
enfin comment les socialistes gère-t-il
l'après dsk martine aubry suggère sa
candidature et se montre aux côtés de
ségolène royal non ce n'est pas un front
anti hollande ont elles assuré juste une
rencontre pour peaufiner le programme
les couteaux s'aiguisent dans la
discrétion et avec nous pour parler de
cette actualité cette semaine patrick
ollier ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement
le parlement bonjour justement vous
connaissez bien vous avez été élue
députée des hautes-alpes en 1989 puis
des hauts-de-seine ans
demi jusqu'en 2010 vous avez même été
élu en 2010 meilleur député de l'année
avec 368 intervention c'est un record et
puis on oublie mais vous avez également
brièvement président de l'assemblée
nationale après la nomination de jean
louis debré au conseil constitutionnel
alors en 2010 vous faites votre entrée
au gouvernement l'occasion de passer de
l'ombre à la lumière avec votre compagne
michèle alliot marie alors ministre des
affaires étrangères pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république un couple occupant même temps
des fonctions ministérielles mais
l'idylle va être de courte durée puisque
en février 2011 après la polémique sur
vos vacances tunisiennes votre compagne
démissionne aujourd'hui vous êtes sur
les bancs du gouvernement elle a
retrouvé son siège de député inversion
des rôles difficiles difficile non pas
par rapport aux fonctions parce que
michel a repris son travail de député
avec enthousiasme parce qu'elle aime ça
c'est conception et elle a des rapports
avec les des habitants de biarritz et
saint-jean-de-luz d'un rapport très
particulier mais probablement michel a
vécu un conte testament michèle alliot
marie avec une tente et seulement des
moments très difficiles
pourquoi le cacher alors pris le dessus
elle a beaucoup de courage beaucoup de
pigna cité mais elle a ressenti tout ça
comme une énorme injustice et c'est
difficile à accepter donc il faut du
temps pour que tout ceci soit accepté
allez y on passe en revue l'actualité de
la semaine avec vous et patrick ollier
et les primaires socialistes qui
s'orientent de plus en plus vers un duel
hollande aubry
en ce début de semaine effectivement se
dessine le profil des prochaines
primaires socialistes martine aubry ira
c'est en tout cas ce qu'elle a laissé
entendre quant à françois hollande déjà
candidat est toujours favori des
sondages il est plus pugnace que jamais
jérémy hartmann il était sur le plateau
de tf1 hier soir martine aubry sur celui
de france 2 un peu plus tôt oubliée la
candidature strauss kahn désormais pour
la primaire socialiste c'est un match
inédit qui se dessine par médias
interposés un duel insoupçonnable il ya
encore dix jours entre une première
secrétaire du ps qui hésitent à se
déclarer et françois hollande le
candidat normal être un candidat normal
je le dis souvent ça suppose des
qualités exceptionnelles parce que faut
être assez exceptionnel pour en même
temps porter une ambition pour son pays
et être humble à l'égard de ceux qui
vous ont donné mandat pour agir
françois hollande ne veut surtout pas
apparaître comme celui qui profitent de
la situation
après l' affaire dsk mais le dernier
sondage le prouve avec 56% d'opinions
favorables il est maintenant le mieux
placé dans la course à l'investiture
socialiste
talonné de près par martine aubry celle
qui avait signé un pacte de non
agression avec dominique strauss kahn se
retrouve sur le devant de la scène
mais face à un françois hollande qu'elle
ne porte pas dans son coeur
la maire de lille hésitent encore à se
lancer officiellement il faut se
préparer je me suis préparé
après la seule chose qui compte parce
que pour moi la politique ce n'est pas
une carrière c'est de se dire à tout
moment où suis je plus utile voilà et
j'ai toujours pris mes responsabilités
les français le savent et je les
prendrai responsables ou frileuse dans
sa démarche
martine aubry reçoit en tout cas le
soutien du porte parole du parti benoît
hamon
et moi je trouve que dans un paysage
politique pour parle beaucoup de
l'ambition des plans de carrière se
placer comme ça dans la situation de
mesurer avec d'autres si on est la mieux
placée pour représenter son camp
montre un vrai sens des responsabilités
reste à savoir quand la première
secrétaire du ps prendra sa décision
les plus optimistes évoquent une
déclaration de candidature dès samedi au
soir de la convention sur le projet
socialiste
alors dans la semaine martine aubry ya a
conforté ses positions face à françois
hollande on l'a vu aux côtés de ségolène
royal à poitiers
elle a aussi reçu le soutien de laurent
fabius
on pressent que la guerre aubry hollande
sera sans pitié c'est une perspective
évidemment si vous réjouit à droite
disant que ça nous attriste pas mais ce
qui est stupéfiant c'est seulement
stupéfiants pourquoi faire un assist un
combat pour être candidat mais mais mais
quel projet pour la france
et qu'est ce qu'on veut faire pour les
français à descendre les airs ce n'en
parle à personne
on a eu la même vie médian excusez moi
on ne parle que de madame aubry qui fait
tant % monsieur hollande temps pour ça
on ne parle plus je ne parle pas du
projet socialiste qui est important
c'est pas qui sera candidat c'est quel
projet pour la france
voilà à partir de là vous voyez bien sûr
bien sûr on l'a lu on a lu et si oui on
peut en parler et
disons que ce programme socialiste qui
regardent dans le rétroviseur et qui
traite la france de demain avec des
méthodes d'avant-hier est un programme
qui est attristant pour le parti qui
veut incarner l'alternative à ce que
nous représentons et la majorité
effectivement cette querelle cette
querelle de nous attriste pas mais c'est
le combat des ombres pour quoi faire et
moi j'attends surtout la confrontation
du projet socialiste par rapport au
projet présidentiel que j'espère nicolas
sarkozy présentera et qui est la
continuité la continuation de ce que
nous avons fait depuis 2007 pour
moderniser et réformer la france qui a
le pardon qui a le plus sale et off pour
être président françois hollande ou
martine aubry
je ne sais pas moi de juger les français
à travers des sondages toutes les
semaines le dise je connais les deux
très sincèrement en dehors des problèmes
des valeurs et des idées ils ont des
qualités tout à fait différente et c'est
aux français d'apprécier le quai les
voix aux socialistes après si martel
reconnaissez-vous avec normale ce qui
est super fier je peux entrer dans cette
polémique mais c'est que monsieur
hollande de 10 avec sérénité je veux
être un président normal mais est repris
dans normal c est être un être
exceptionnel porte des valeurs etc
si être normal ces êtres exceptionnels
je ne suis pas sûr que dans tout ce qui
se présente
yann et qui puisse être qualifié très
sincèrement les qualités de martine
aubry
des qualités martine aubry et c'est une
adversaire pugnace parce que nous avons
des idées
qui sont tout à fait différentes disons
que françois hollande est plus centrale
dans le positionnement de la gauche
madame aubry est plus à gauche
j'ai pas oublier les combats pour les 35
heures puisque j'étais président de la
mission d'information sur les 35 heures
dans monsieur novelli était le
rapporteur
j'ai pas oublier c'est quand ben moi je
respecte beaucoup madame aubry parce
qu'elle est convaincue de ses idées
jeudi que ses idées sont mauvaises pas
la même chose mais elle est intimement
convaincu de ses idées le seul problème
c'est que tant que les socialistes n'ont
pas fait ce qu'on appelle le coming out
c'est à dire qu'ils n'auront pas réglé
le problème au sein du parti socialiste
entre ceux qui sont sociaux-démocrates
et qui aurait pu se rattacher à strauss
kahn et aller vers une sorte de social
centrisme et ceux qui sont ni aux
marxistes et qui sont à gauche du parti
comme monsieur hamon madame aubry
tant qu'il n'aura pas tranché entre ces
deux tendances ils n'arriveront pas
incarner une alternative sérieuse et
crédible par rapport à notre majorité
qu'ils arrivent à choisir mais parce
qu'il n'arrive pas à choisir les partis
de la gauche du parti socialiste
oui qui était tout à fait imprégné de la
pensée marxiste mais je critique sur le
fond mais c'est respectable d'avoir des
idées auxquelles on croit même si ces
idées sont mauvaises pour le pays et
pour la france quand on voit leur
programme leur peau leur programme qui
propose quoi d'augmenter la dépense
publique
quoi de recruter trois cent mille
emplois jeunes est payé avec la dépense
publique alors que tout ou le toute
l'europe est en train de se battre pour
réduire la dépense publique parce qu'on
n'arrive plus à payer nos dettes que ce
soit à regarder l'espagne regarder dans
quelle situation est en train de se
trouver c'est ahurissant de voir que les
socialistes viennent aujourd'hui dire
aux français et bien non ce que fait la
majorité n'est pas bien revenons au port
ses arrières avec beaucoup de démagogie
c'est l'état qui doit tout payer
plus loin on a vu que la chute de
dominique strauss kahn n'a pas du tout
profité à nicolas sarkozy dans les
sondages tout le monde c'est reporté
tous les acteurs potentiels se sont
reportés sur françois hollande ou
martine aubry
le président arrive toujours loin au
deuxième problème mais le phénomène ne
me surprend pas la sphère de strauss
kahn c'est la sphère de monsieur strauss
kahn c'est pas la sphère du parti
socialiste et c'est pas la sphère de la
france
quand j'ai vu les amalgames m un
candidat s'étant excusé moi oui d'accord
mais mais mais ce n'est pas pour autant
que ceux qui voulaient voter à gauche
parce que monsieur strauss kahn est
disqualifié ne vous trompe lui à gauche
c'est le problème de monsieur strauss
kahn ça arrive la gauche d'un candidat
potentiel mais ça n'enlève pas de voix
la gauche voit pas pourquoi parce que
monsieur strauss kahn disqualifié ceux
qui croyaient en alternance socialiste
brutalement se tournerait vers nous
apprend dans cette annexe trouve ardent
c'est à nous de convaincre par rapport à
notre projet et nicolas sarkozy aura
tout le talent pour le faire à partir
d'un bilan qui est très positif
j'aimerais qu'on en parle aussi c'est un
autre convaincre les français que ces
verrous qu'il faut porter leur à propos
de dominique strauss kahn un mot quand
même on a vu les images de dsk
l'apparence plutôt détendu sortie de
l'ancien appartement pour aller vivre
dans une luxueuse maison quelques blocs
loin on a aussi découvert sur internet
le luxe dans lequel va vivre l'ex
dirigeant du fmi
cette image vous ont choqué ce qui me
choque surtout c'est le souvenir le
souvenir monsieur strauss kahn qui
lorsque hervé gaymard a été justifié de
manière tout à fait une qualifiable
attaqué parce qu'il avait un appartement
de fonction allouée par l'état et que
monsieur strauss kahn avait fait une
relation entre le prix de ce loyer et le
niveau de vie qu'on a respecté quand un
homme public
on voit qu'il s'est appliqué à nicholas
des règles pour l'élève qu'il aurait sur
des frileux rire ça ne s'est pas le
problème du niveau de vie d'annoncer le
problème du niveau de vie s'ils prennent
la relation entre le niveau de vie voilà
strauss kahn ne s'est pas appliqué à lui
les règles qu'ils voulaient voir
appliquée aux autres je trouve un peu un
peu choquant cet étalage d'argent
effectivement ça donne l'impression peut
lorsqu'on a beaucoup d'argent
on peut avoir des traitements différents
et que l'on soit riche ou misérable etc
etc tout cas vivement aux etats unis
c'est comme ça que ça se passe à
deauville on a vu un nicolas sarkozy en
souriant qui prenait un bain de foule
avec barack obama il est quand même
content que l'absence de dominique
strauss kahn sa une
l'ue a pas volé la vedette jeudi postale
se porta que le président de la
république soit content que la raison
nous indiquer le bonheur d'un public est
certainement heureux de constater que
tous les clignotants économiques passent
au vert en france que la croissance est
annoncée par l' ocde en 2011 plus
importante que le gouvernement de la
prévu de 2,2 pour cent que le chômage
est en train d'être de diminué pour le
quatrième mois consécutif
oui ça c'est de nature à faire plaisir
au président car ça prouve que la
politique il a mis en oeuvre depuis 2007
porte ses fruits
et qu'en plus il arrive à convaincre les
grands de ce monde à travers le g8
d'engager une politique qui va permettre
d'apaiser les relations entre les
continents
dans le cadre de la politique
internationale sur le plan des des
traitements des crises internationales
prouve la piña cité de nicolas sarkozy
ça c'est de nature à lui donner du
bonheur et à le rendre souriant points
de plus qu'en se réjouir quand on est
français
allez on passe au mardi avec un climat
de rébellion du groupe ump à l'assemblée
nationale en cause les radars les
panneaux signalant les radars seront ils
démontent et mardi les députés de la
majorité opposés à cette mesure est
signataire d'une pétition envoyée à
françois fillon ont cru obtenir gain de
cause avec l'annoncé d'un moratoire sur
le démontage de ces panneaux
retour sur cette cacophonie avec kamal
abu rahim
cette fois ci le bras de fer tourne à
l'avantagé des députés ump
fait rare 80 d'entre eux avaient écrit
la veille à françois fillon pour dire
leur malaise
ces derniers sont visiblement ravis du
volte-face du gouvernement sur la
signalisation des radars
nous avons transmis la réaction
extrêmement négative delà de la
population et le gouvernement tout en
maintenant les objectifs a manifestement
magnifique modifier le style c'est ce
qu'il fallait obtenir
j'en ai assez de cette espèce
d'hypocrisie du gouvernement qui prétend
lutter contre la violence routière et
qui fait que de l'argent en cous le
démontage de ces fameux panneaux
ce dernier avait d'ailleurs déjà
commencé un peu partout aujourd'hui
marche arrière de claude guéant en lieu
et place des panneaux radars dits
pédagogiques qui signalent la vitesse
d'un automobiliste sans pour autant le
sanctionner il n'y a pas de reculades
les panneaux signalant la présence de
radars fixes seront enlevés mais j'ai
voulu avec l'accord du premier ministre
a ajouté une dimension à notre lutte en
faveur de la sécurité routière a tout à
fait absolument il n'y a pas l'épaisseur
d'une feuille de papier à cigarette
entre nous ça va de soi la veille le
premier ministre avait pourtant assuré
qu'il n'y aurait pas de retours sur la
question une mission parlementaire sur
les causes des accidents de la route a
été actée ce matin en attendant leurs
conclusions
aucune loi portant sur la sécurité
routière ne devrait être modifié ils se
sont réjouis un peu trop vite les
députés ump il ya une certaine
cacophonie autour d'un sujet sensible la
sécurité routière comment vous
l'expliquez de quoi parlons nous parle
de 4000 morts par an et on parle de
l'augmentation brutale pour des raisons
qui restent à analyser de l'augmentation
de ces morts sur la route
le gouvernement est comptable des
efforts que la nation fait pour empêcher
des jeunes des moins jeunes de se tuer
sur la route qui n'a pas été touchée par
un mort ou un blessé dans sa famille
puis trois cent mille blessés par an
donc le gouvernement constatant
l'augmentation de mort dit tout ce qu'on
a fait jusqu'à présent est dépassé il
faut revoir notre politique est
effectivement des mesures ont été prises
alors qu'elle était mal comprise qu'elle
était mal interprété qu'elle était mal
dit peut-être
et ça ça ne suffit pas y'a vraiment
françois fillon mais l'a dit un jour non
enlève les panneaux avertissent à le
lendemain claude guéant dit on suspend
l'enlèvement des panneaux en verre d'eau
ça sera coordonnée moi ce sont des
interprétations d'un amant j'étais
présent non j'étais présent quand les
choses ont été dites
le premier ministre n'a jamais changé
d'avis monsieur guéant et le premier
ministre sont tout à fait d'accord
les interprétations des personnes qui
leur sont les journalistes qui ont mal
compris
peut-être peut-être que cela a été mal
expliqué car les journalistes n'étaient
pas présents car les choses ont été
dites moi je n'en sais rien mais j'étais
pressé les députés ump herman quand
madame j'étais présent j'ai entendu ce
qui s'est dit je vous dis la vérité il
n'y a pas de changement le président de
république a donné des instructions
alors que les choses étaient mal
interprété c'est fort possible qu'elle
ait été mal rapportés peut-être qu'ils
aient eu des erreurs de commises sur le
plan de la communication peut-être aussi
le fait est que les mesures qui sont
prises sont bien celles que monsieur
bien on vient de confirmer et que des
les députés qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit
députés ils ont raison de dire ça ils
ont fait part de la réaction épidermique
des personnes qui se sont sentis touchés
dans leur travail au quotidien parce
qu'ils ont senti une sorte de contrainte
supplémentaire
ils ont dit il faut faire attention il
faut être prudent pour faire la part des
choses entre ceux qui sont des tueurs la
route avec à cause de l'alcool de la
drogue mais présenté ceux qui
travaillent aux côtés des signataires
n'ont pas été entendus puisque les
panneaux avertissent ils ont été
entendus est retiré non il peut pas
pardonner mois ils ont ils ont été en
moins il ya eu un dialogue entre le
gouvernement et sa majorité
est-ce qu'il est anormal que le
gouvernement et sa majorité puissent
dialoguer sur un sujet aussi important
c'est pas normal donc de quoi on
s'étonne on s'étonne qu'ils aient un
dialogue et qui a été constructif
puisque les députés qui ont fait part de
leur émoi ont été entendus et que la
conclusion de ce dialogue c'est pas le
changement des décisions qui ont été
prises
c'est leur mise en oeuvre ses modalités
de mise en oeuvre qui évolue pour tenir
compte de leurs réactions et monsieur
guéant a dit quoi il a dit que les
panneaux allaient être enlevées
ils vont l'être mais qu' on va prendre
le temps pour les enlever de créer des
commissions locales pour voir comment il
faut gérer
l'enlèvement des panneaux et les
remplacer par des radars pédagogiques
qui seront remis de manière aléatoire
aléatoire pas à la place des panneaux le
long des parcours concernés moi j'étais
couché avec moi j'étais touché
personnellement de ma famille parce que
quelqu'un de très proche qui est mort
dans la voiture dans laquelle j'étais
dans un accident
je sais ce que c'est qu'un accident bien
et bien et pourtant j'aime aller vite
quand je conduis eh bien je dis que
effectivement pour éviter qu'un drame se
produise de gouvernement a raison d'être
courageux monsieur sarkozy et monsieur
fillon en raison de ne pas faire de
l'électoralisme
quand on sait que 50% de ses 4000 morts
sur des gens qui comme vous comme moi
roule sur la route sans avoir rien fait
de mal et se retrouve amputée d'un
enfant d'une paire ou d'homère par un
accident vieilley à des criminels de la
route
voilà ce qu'ont fait obstacle à des
excès de ce genre alors on continue
mardi un tous les sénateurs de gauche
s'étaient réunies pour lancer la
campagne des sénatoriales
fort d'un sondage sur les malaises dans
les territoires jean pierre bel chef de
file des socialistes au sénat espère
bien profiter du mécontentement des élus
locaux qui sont aussi les grands
électeurs ont l'écoutent lecture que je
fais c'est que les gens sont
profondément mécontent de la situation
des services publics locaux
ils sont mécontents également du
désengagement de l'état dans les
départements puisque c'est un mouvement
aussi concomitants et alors ils sont
très mécontent de ce que les compétences
nouvelles qui leur sont dévolues ne sont
pas compensés financièrement je crois
que c'est plutôt de nature à nous
conforter nous qui se tend à attirer
l'attention de tous les élus locaux sur
la situation qui leur est faite et je
pense que le malaise des territoires
dont on parle est une vraie réalité que
secondes ce sondage a contribué à en
illustrer ce malaise dans les
territoires avec la réforme de la poste
la réforme de la fiscalité locale ou
encore la réforme territoriale est ce
que vous pensez que ça peut influencer
le vote des grands électeurs le 25
septembre
si vous demandez au président du groupe
socialiste au sénat
mais chez jean pierre bel pour lequel
j'ai beaucoup de respect d'ailleurs
ce qu'il en pense forcément illogique
qu'ils disent ce qu'il vient de dire il
est logique qu'ils essaient de profiter
d'une perception des choses pour
traduire ça en terme électoral pour la
prochaine campagne sénatoriale est ce
que cela correspond à une réalité je ne
le crois pas je ne le crois pas la
perception des choses est différente de
la réalité des choses
l'inter de dire que par exemple les
nouvelles compétences sont pas compensés
c'est faux c'est compensé au centime
près il suffit de lire le budget de
l'état pour voir les que les transferts
correspondent au centime près et semble
sont prélevés transférés dans les
départements de ski accord il ya
transfert de compétences alors lancé ce
n'est peut-être pas celle là je le
reconnai volontier
moi j'ai confiance pour le futur sénat
et j'ai confiance
la belle si la gauche est ce que c'est
une alternance possible joignable j'ai
confiance pour le futur sénat j'ai
confiance à une majorité d'aujourd'hui
qui resterait la majorité de demain et
je suis convaincu quand même je le
souhaite mais je le souhaite ardemment
mais je suis convaincu aussi que gérard
larcher qui est un action présent
dictionnaire restera président du sénat
mais il est un sénat à gauche non
président un camp non entrés en jeu
droite ça donnerait du travail au
ministre en charge des relations très
parlement ne peut pas l'imaginer si vous
préférez et que je parle comme ça parce
qu'effectivement ça me donnerait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de travail
mais on a imaginé tous les cas de figure
et j'ai très bien comment il faudrait
travailler dans ce cas là mais je répète
je suis serein et confiant et je
n'imagine pas que le sénat puisse
basculer qu'on ait quelques pertes
oui au point de perdre la majorité et
que me que nous perdions la présidence
du sénat je répète non allez on va
passer au mercredi christine lagarde se
verrait bien en successeur de dsk
oui bien sûr
christine lagarde m la communication
efficace en ce mercredi la ministre de
l'économie convoque la presse à bercy
annonce la couleur dès la première
phrase elle est candidate au poste de
directeur général du fmi
l' affaire tapie dans laquelle elle est
mise en cause ce n'est pas un problème
car selon elle le dossier est creux
thomas souliers c'était un secret de
polichinelle mais sa candidature à la
direction générale du fmi est désormais
acté ce midi à bercy devant une nuée de
caméras christine lagarde se lance
officiellement dans la course
j'ai décidé de présenter ma candidature
à la direction générale du fonds
monétaire international c'est un immense
défi que j'aborde avec beaucoup
d'humilité et en souhaitant recueillir
le plus large consensus
sa candidature est appuyé par nicolas
sarkozy et une grande partie des
dirigeants européens
mais à gauche elle fait beaucoup moins
l'unanimité les socialistes juge
christine lagarde trop libéral et
surtout trop impliqué dans l' affaire
tapie la ministre de l'économie est
menacée d'une enquête judiciaire pour un
arbitrage en faveur de l'homme
d'affaires
après ses démêlés avec le crédit
lyonnais je mets en garde de manière
très solennelle et le gouvernement et le
président de la république et surtout
madame lagarde sur le fait qu'il y a une
épée de damoclès qui pèse très
lourdement sur la tête de madame lagarde
ne faudrait 50 2
en ahl éclater la tête du fonds
monétaire international parce que là
franchement
pour la france c'est sain
fatal le successeur de dominique strauss
kahn sera désigné le 30 juin
alors on va relayer l'interrogation des
socialistes patrick ollier la france
peut-elle risquer une nouvelle démission
d'un patron français du fmi
d'abord j'aimerais que les socialistes
que lui demandant de parler et la même
distance par rapport à l'événement
nomination de directeur général du fmi
que nous l'avons eue nous à droite
lorsqu'il s'est agi de soutenir les
canadiens mais là c'est une vraie
question excusez moi est ce que c'est
moi
non non mais je vais répondre à la
deuxième partie de la question revient
pas de la question
c'est la personne la plus compétente au
poste le plus important pour l'europe et
la france
c'est ce poste de directeur général est
la plus compétente en europe aujourd'hui
tout le monde s'accorde à le reconnaître
c'est christine lagarde qui a d'immenses
qualités que chacun se plaît à
reconnaître et bien lorsqu'il s'est agi
de nommer monsieur strauss kahn la
droite a soutenu monsieur strauss-kahn
qui était pourtant un candidat de gauche
il y avait des tas de raisons pour dire
qu'on n'était pas d'accord on ne l'a pas
fait dante acte ils font le contraire
c'est une attitude politicienne que je
relève s'agissant maintenant des risques
que vous évoquez je soutient madame
lagarde avoir à titre personnel parce
que j'ai énormément travaillé avec elle
en tant que président la commission of
economic l'assemblée nationale en même
temps que j'ai cette fonction à l'été
mon interlocutrice sujet plus là jugé et
je dis que sincèrement elle est de loin
la plus compétente
j'étais aussi se trouve que gt5 en juge
à la cour de justice de la république je
sais comment fonctionne cette
institution très sincèrement dans le
dossier qu'on évoque sur l' affaire
tapie je ne vois pas sauf à ce que on
apporte une preuve contraire je ne vois
pas ce qui peut on aller plus haut
magistrat de france jean louis nadal
procureur près de la cour de cassation
qui a estimé qu'ils avaient peut-être
abus de pouvoir on peut estimer au je
suis à dole on peut estimer aujourd'hui
qui éventuellement un jour christine
lagarde puisse aller devant la cour de
justice de la république ce n'est pas
exclue on le saura le 10 juin
est-ce que c'est compatible avec une
candidature au poste pour un poste qui
sera désigné le 30 juin
vous allez donnez vous même la réponse
on saura le 10 juin s'il ya matière à
aller plus loin pour la cour du si de la
république alors si si la réponse est
oui si ce bien vers une enquête bien que
est ce que christine lagarde peut
maintenir sa candidature ce moment là
madame lagarde appeler sir elle même ce
qu'elle va faire
moi je vous dis qu'il n'ya pas dans
l'état actuel des choses ma connaissance
des dossiers et quoi que ce soit qui
implique que ça puisse aller seul
dossier creux madame lagarde l'a dit je
confirme en tout cas ce sentiment là que
le plus haut magistrat concerné par cela
procure générale décide de pour être
bien sûr qu'ils aient pas de problème
pour éviter les suspicions pour éviter
que toute la classe politique de gaujac
vous voyez le parquet est sous les
ordres du gouvernement qui empêchait qui
est une enquête
la transparence la plus totale il décide
de faire faire une enquête
qu'est ce qui lie à d'anormal dans cela
la décision de pour la nomination
éventuellement demandent à garth et je
le répète le 30 juin
et c'est le 10 juin qu'on sera si ça va
ou pas devant la cour de justice entre
le 10 et le 30 il ya un délai suffisant
pour faire face à ses responsabilités en
cas de changement est visible mais mme
lagarde
mon avis n'a pas trop de soucis à se
faire pour cela l'important c'est qu'on
soit tous derrière pour la soutenir et
qui est pas de cafouillage
parce que si cela apparaît comme une
division en france par rapport au
candidat de la france
ça peut porter tort à sa candidature au
regard des pays étrangers pour la
décision finale ça serait dommage mais
ce serait la responsabilité des
socialistes mercredi cette affaire qui
met en cause georges tron secrétaire
d'état à la fonction publique
il est accusé d'agression sexuelle et de
viol par deux anciennes employées de
draveil en essonne commune dont il est
le maire deux plaintes ont été déposées
georges tron il
faits et entend à son tour porté plainte
pour dénonciation calomnieuse
betty lachguer des gestes déplacés c'est
ce dont est accusé l'actuel secrétaire
d'état à la fonction publique georges
tron la plainte dévoilée par le parisien
a été déposée par deux ex employées
municipales est confirmée par leurs
avocats
et aujourd'hui par les deux plaignantes
sont allés elle-même au parquet déposé
leur plainte en personne
où est chez leur détermination
selon les deux victimes le maire ump de
draveil dans l'essonne se serait permis
de leur caresser les pieds sous couvert
de pratiquer la réflexologie des gestes
selon elle qui s'apparentait à de
véritables agressions leur plainte est
soutenu par l'association européenne
contre les violences faites aux femmes
de son côté le parquet d'evry a d'ores
et déjà ouvert une enquête préliminaire
pour harcèlement sexuel contre georges
tron mais si les faits sont avérés ils
pourraient être qualifiés d'agression
sexuelle et même de viol
georges tron lui rejette toutes ces
accusations ministre expliquera que
leurs plates aussi étayait soit elle de
jolie définition juridique si j'ai bien
compris des pas davantage fondées et
puis à m'adresser des tribunaux qui ment
départager les protagonistes
finalement le secrétaire d'état devrait
à son tour porté plainte pour
dénonciation calomnieuse
prudence du côté de l'ump je peux pas
vous en dire beaucoup plus je sais que
georges tron doit s'exprimer sur ce
sujet et que l occasion de son
expression il donnera certainement des
éléments qui sont de nature à ne pas
tout mélanger
la plainte vise également une proche de
georges tron soupçonné de complicité
le secrétaire d'état avant de faire
l'objet d'une éventuelle incrimination
devrait répondre aux questions de la
police judiciaire dans les jours à venir
alors est-ce que vous pensez que georges
tron devrait quitter le gouvernement
pour mieux organiser sa défense dans
cette affaire
mon dieu que les médias vont vite et
conclue avant même que les
les éléments étaient prouvés présomption
d'innocence
je l'entends de dire là je confirme moi
aussi que la présomption d'innocence
doit prévaloir pour qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs au passage mais y compris
pour monsieur tron aussi et d'avoir vu
dans la presse la photo de georges tron
à côté de celle de monsieur berlusconi
et de strauss kahn avec une prostituée à
côté en expliquant que tout ceci était
pareil je trouve cela odieux
je trouve ça choquant je connais georges
tron depuis plus de 30 ans je n'imagine
pas au jour d'aujourd'hui
un tel comportement violent vous
imaginez ce que ça veut dire violent on
a envoyé un mot qui est qui a fleuri
cette semaine dans la presse sûrement
avec influence de la presse américaine
c'est la présomption de sincérité quand
même des plaignants pour la reconnaissez
aussi la présomption ça c'est la vérité
de la part des plats nouvelle mais il ya
les deux la présomption d'innocence
guy prévost aussi et violent c'est
énorme viol c'est quelque chose qui est
terrible venue du jeune et que je ne
vois jusqu'à qualifier les faits pendant
c'est le juge qui a qualifié les faits
n'ont pas encore là
on verra on verra s'il est mis en examen
à ce moment là les choses seront
différentes mais pour l'instant il n'est
pas de la nature de la plainte ça sert
de la rente au viol
mais oui d'accord la nature de la
plainte mais je dis qu'il faut quand
même attendre que les choses se
déroulent et qu'il y ait une action
judiciaire officiellement lancée en
dehors d'une enquête préliminaire qui
est tout à fait logique en la
circonstance et que jusque là la dame la
présomption d'innocence prévaut
moi j'ai confiance en georges tron je
n'imagine pas dans une telle situation
prudence donc alors en ce mercredi
également les sénateurs se penchent sur
la question de leur conflit d'intérêts
la commission des lois présente quarante
propositions qui vont de la déclaration
d'intérêts obligatoire à la limitation
des revenus annexes
résumé de jérôme radio premiers pas de
la haute assemblée pour limiter les
conflits d'intérêts de ses sénateurs un
groupe de travail avance 40 propositions
pour oeuvrer dans ce sens si elles sont
adoptées une déclaration d'intérêts
serait obligatoire pour chaque sénateur
il figurerait ses activités ses
rémunérations et les éventuels intérêts
professionnels et financiers de l'élu et
de son entourage familial proche avec un
objectif clair
nécessité d'une déclaration d'intérêts
pour permettre à chacun de s'interroger
d'abord et ensuite si les conflits
d'intérêts paraissent trop important par
rapport à l'intérêt général est bien
c'est que on puisse prendre des
sanctions éventuelles contre les ceux
qui ne respecteraient pas ces normes
éthiques pour sanctionner les
déclarations incomplètes ou mensongères
une autorité serait nommé composée de
sénateurs de toutes les formations
politiques présentes au sénat certaines
activités professionnelles seraient
également incompatible avec la fonction
de sénateur
une des propositions visent même à
limiter les revenus engrangés en dehors
de son activité de sénateur un montant
qui ne devrait pas dépasser la moitié de
l'indemnité dé lui je ne trouve pas
normal non plus que l'on puisse avoir
revenus la débilité parlementaire et que
hongrie six ou sept fois par ailleurs
dans une activité professionnelle je
peux douter qu'on se consacre avant tout
à son mandat parlementaire plus de
transparence c'est le voeu du groupe de
travail sur les conflits d'intérêts
reste maintenant à mettre en place tout
ou partie de ces mesures
après le renouvellement de la haute
assemblée de septembre prochain alors ça
va dans le bon sens évidemment
l'assemblée déjà avait fait ses
propositions
est ce qu'il faudrait quand même un code
de bonne conduite commun aux deux
assemblées parce que là finalement pour
l'instant chacune des deux assemblées a
fait ses propositions
c'est la spécificité française mais
d'une manière générale je suis très
favorable à ce que je viens d'entendre
la part du président y est qui et qui
est reconnue dans ce domaine là comme
quelqu'un de très compétent je suis tout
à fait d'accord je pense que pour que
les élus retrouvent garde pour ce qu'il
en gardait la confiance des électeurs
il faut la plus grande transparence il
faut éviter qu'il puisse y avoir des
questions qui se posent et pour éviter
qu'ils aient des questions qui se posent
il faut ouvrir tous les outils de la
discipline a bien sûr bien sûr silicium
en commençant sanctions ça n'a pas
d'intérêt il faut qu est qu une sanction
donc moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
pour créer des déclarations d'ailleurs
je vous signale que les ministres sont
soumis à ces déclarations d'intérêts
j'ai moi même
même rédigé damienne les cabinets pour
les parlementaires ils se soient rendus
publics les cabinets ministériels sans
souci collaborateurs ont tous rempli des
documents et à partir de là il faut qui
est une autorité qui puisse surveiller
sa peau pas publiques ça veut dire quoi
publier que ce soit sur internet a vu et
su de tous je ne pense pas que ce soit
organisé les députés oui mais je pense
pas que ce soit opportun ce niveau là ce
qui est important c'est qu'une autorité
qu'ils puissent contrôler qu'il y a
faute ou pas pierre fois qu'ils y avoir
sanction je suis d'accord avec vous pour
savoir s'il faut que ce soit sur les
sites d'internet et je suis pas sûr que
ce soit la bonne méthode il ya un aspect
important qui est l'incompatibilité de
sanctions gérard larcher lui même dit
que 160 organisation extra-parlementaire
ou des sénateurs sont présents sont de
nature à entraîner des conflits
d'intérêts c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est gérard larcher est ce que il faut
qu'il y ait une liste établie
d'organismes dont devra démissionner un
député à partir moment il est élu je
pense que ce serait bien qu'il y ait
effectivement une vision de ce genre là
comme je le répète c'est fait pour le
gouvernement ou un membre du
gouvernement est amené à démissionner de
la présidence d'une société qu'il peut
dirigés en étant élu un détail lui ça a
été mon cas j'ai fait nécessaire parce
quand on est élu local on peut présider
des sociétés d'économie mixte
d'aménagement expliqué c'était juste
qu'il pouvait y avoir des conflits
d'intérêts pour l'instant n'y a aucune
obligation donc oui je suis en train de
vous dire que ça serait bien qu'il y ait
une référence parce que ensuite c'est la
discussion qui donnait qui doit
permettre de dire ah ben oui peut-être
mais shy pas si elle listes claires et
précises qui précise qu' on ne peut pas
être en même temps parlementaires
députés ou sénateurs d'ailleurs plus
d'accord avec vous ça serait bien que
tout ceci soit unifiée et en même temps
exercé des fonctions de président tel ou
telle société ou dans le privé telle ou
telle activité qui peut être en conflit
avec les lois que l'on connaît est amené
à voter ça serait sain comme une telle
liste soit effectivement terme en
identifier les allées deauville sous
haute sécurité pour accueillir le sommet
du g8 un sommet sous présidence
française avec un programme chargé les
grandes puissances de ce monde sont
invités à réfléchir à l'après printemps
arabe et à l'afrique démocratique kathia
gilder ils sont venus ils sont tous là
les chefs d'état des huit pays les plus
puissants du monde ont défilé ensemble
pour ouvrir ce 37ème sommet de deauville
mais si l'ambiance est décontractée les
sujets de discussion sont pourtant bien
sérieux pour ce g8 organisé sous
présidence française
un sommet que paris a placé sous le
signe des révolutions arabes avec pour
objectif le déblocage d'une aide
économique en faveur de l'egypte et la
tunisie
je pense que rien n'est possible si les
peuples de se mettre en marche mais rien
n'est possible pour ces peuples si on ne
les aide pas et donc la question de la
réussite de la révolution tunisienne et
de la révolution égyptienne est
absolument centrale
la france souhaite aussi profiter de ce
g8 pour accentuer la pression
internationale sur le syrien bachar
el-assad est sûre muamar kadhafi
un homme qui a employé l'artillerie
l'aviation pour tirer sur une foule
innocente et d amener après 41 ans de
dictature ne peut pas rester en place
message bien reçu par les autres
dirigeants à une exception près celle du
russe medvedev qui continue de soutenir
le président syrien alors que ses
partenaires l'ont déjà sanctionné les
discussions se poursuivront ce vendredi
à huit clos sous très haute surveillance
alors le g8 durci le ton contre le
régime libyen de mouammar kadhafi
il a perdu toute légitimité est ce qu il
doit partir selon vous d'abord je
voudrais dire que je suis fier pointe
français de voir le g8 organisé en
france deauville se suffire pour le
français de voir le présent de la
république être le leader de ce g8 et
j'aimerais que les français
reconnaissent que la position et
l'action du président sarkozy au niveau
international l'ont conduit aujourd'hui
à faire ce qu'il fait ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui le résultat d'une action
conduite depuis 2007
chapeau monsieur le président c'est en
tout cas la conception des choses vous
poser une question précise
dans le cadre de la libye la réponse est
oui c'est la france qui a été à
l'origine de la prise de conscience
internationale et du soutien apporté à
ces pays en émergence de démocratie
plaint que ce soit l'egypte la libye est
aujourd'hui la syrie et si on peut pas
aller plus loin pour la syrie j'espère
ça pourrait se régler ou c'est pourquoi
c'est parce qu'il ya des vétos qui sont
les vétos de la notamment de la russie
c'est un des derniers qui reste et qui
empêche de prendre des mesures plus
contraignantes
donc il est bien que la france soit à
l'origine de tout cela vous à
m'approcher patrick ollier à une époque
je suis dit allez vous ferez les
questions d'avoir donner un vernis de
respectabilité
au colonel kadhafi avec des phrases
comme il lit montesquieu et c'est là
vous avez entendu nicolas sarkozy qui
dit c'est un homme qui tire sur son
peuple
est-ce que c'était une erreur
d'appréciation avec le recul vous pouvez
dire ça d'abord j'ai jamais dit qu'il
disait montesquieu j'ai dit je lui ai
offert mais attendez il faut aussi
savoir ce qui est dit je lui dis que je
lui ai offert montesquieu pour l'esprit
des lois pour le faire mûrir dans sa
réflexion démocratique puisqu'il
m'expliquer ça n'a pas marché mais je le
confesse ça n'a pas marché ça valait le
coup d'essayer en tout cas parce que à
l'époque il s'agissait de se faire en
sorte de se rapprocher de la libye pour
que les bijoux z contre l'immigration
clandestine venant du tchad et cetera
pour que la libye est de l'europe à la
france seulement mais l'europe contre al
qaïda les basaltes cada qui s'installait
et qu'il y avait des rapprochements qui
étaient des rapprochements d'intérêt
commun très bien donc j'ai eu je me dis
qu'il disait déjà il parle pas français
je pense pas qu'il ait pu lire remonter
ce que dans le texte c'était une pièce
dit que je faisais cela étant je
regrette que ce n'est pas fonctionné et
je regrette que tout ce qui a été fait
pour faire en sorte que le présent cas
du colonel kadhafi évoluent les conduit
à réagir comme il a réagi de manière
aussi violente contre son peuple
dire que on a on a cru qu'on allait y
arriver mais sa réaction le condamne et
jeux en tant que démocrate je ne peux
que moi aussi partager cette
condamnation la partie des reproches
patrick ollier sans les printemps arabes
on vous a donc reproché d'être allé
passer vos vacances en tunisie au moment
de la de la répression des émeutes des
manifestations pardon est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
vous reconnaissez qu'il est bon d'aider
la tunisie et l'egypte vers la voie de
la démocratisation
d'abord une mise au point nous n'étions
pas en tunisie lors des émeutes c'est
faux c'est faux les manifestations des
premières manifestations des arrêts non
mais manifestation 17 décembre où les
émeutes ont commencé à partir du 7 au 8
janvier nous étions rentrés depuis
plusieurs jours en france et les émeutes
n'ont rien à voir avec notre présence
avec la divergence de vue ma passion je
suis sensible là dessus pour michel pour
sa famille et pour moi aussi parce qu'il
ne faut pas faire d'amalgamé il faut pas
dire dès aujourd'hui faut-il je vous
retire les délais de réponse oui et je
sais quelle façon les packs la tunisie
si je suis ami avec les tunisiens
d'étudiants de demain comme ceux
d'aujourd'hui ou ceux d'hier
daniel tunisien le peuple tunisien ben
ali il rencontre une fois dans ma vie un
voyage officiel avec le président de la
république
tapez hamid ben ali mais en revanche
j'ai beaucoup d'amis tunisien c'est
parce que ce sont des des peuples j'ai
passé les quinze premières années de ma
vie de ce côté de l'atlantique de
l'amitié pardon toi je veux dire je suis
très sensible à l'évolution de ces
peuples là et et tout le tour de
méditerranée
c'est notre affaire à nous la france
autant que celle d'autres pays qui ça
n'occupe pas d'ailleurs et nous on veut
s'en occuper
donc on a intérêt au développement de
ces pays pour des tas de raisons pour
laquelle je pointerais ça serait trop
lent notamment l'immigration clandestine
qui est la conséquence de la misère dans
ces pays oui il faut les aider
un avenant de l'argent les marchandises
et l'élection aussi à garder de l'argent
mais d'utiliser leur développement et
paula permettre du progrès et
effectivement leur ramener la compétence
en matière démocratie même si démocratie
n'est pas parfaite que nous avons pour
mettre en place des institutions et des
fonctionnement démocratique
je crois que tous les voyages qui ont
lieu en ce moment et je crois savoir que
même le prix dans l'assemblée nationale
en ce moment et dans un des pays du
maghreb où il va pas démocratie sont
faits pour apporter notre expertise
notre connaissance est bien placé après
avoir soutenu le président ben ali mais
la france est bien placée oui elle a
soutenu la tunisie mais il a soutenu la
tunisie qui ne soutenait pas le
président ben ali quand il était en
fonction ce pic helmand un pays qui est
condamné le président ben ali
personne il a été élu démocratiquement
que c'est des résultats d'élections qui
n'ont fait accéder au pouvoir et la
france était comme tous les pays avaient
des relations officielles d'état et avec
le président ben ali
la france soutient la tunisie et les
tunisiens donc demain
il est important que nous soyons
capables d'apporter et le fait que les
responsables tunisiens
les responsables égyptiens soit
aujourd'hui présent en france est bon
signe c'est nicolas sarkozy qui les a
invités pour que l'ensemble du g8 leur
apporte un soutien financier pour
conduire leur développement vers la
démocratie
c'est bon signe c'est positif et c'est
ça patrick hollande va terminer
l'actualité de la semaine avec
l'arrestation du serbe ratko mladic en
fuite depuis 16 ans le boucher des
balkans comme on l'appelait était le
principal instigateur de l'épuration
ethnique en bosnie notez dans la
localité de sebrenica en 95 kamal abu
rain ratko mladic l'homme le plus
recherché en europe par la justice
internationale vient d'être arrêté
l'annoncé a été faite un peu après 13h
par le président serbe
au nom de la république de serbie je
vous annonce que ratko mladic a été
arrêté aujourd'hui dans la matinée ratko
mladic surnommé le boucher des balkans
était en fuite depuis 1995 et une
inculpation par le tribunal pénal
international pour l'ex yougoslavie
commandant des forces serbes de bosnie
il mène alors une vaste campagne de
nettoyage ethnique
le 11 juillet 1995 il prend lé enclave
de srebrenica et fait exécuter près de
8000 musulmans le pire massacre depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale
son transfert vers l'est est en cours
l'annnonce de son arrestation est
unanimement salué par la communauté
internationale
c'est une très grande nouvelle
c'est une décision très courageuse du
président serbe
et c'est une étape de plus vers
l'intégration un jour prochain de la
serbie dans l'union européenne car
belgrade a souvent été accusé de couvrir
ces criminels de guerre un sondage a été
réalisé au début du mois de mai
40% des serbes eux considéraient encore
ratko mladic comme un héros
la serbie a gagné ses galons pour entrer
dans l'union européenne
les enveloppes d'abord cette omelette un
barbare il mérite de finir ses jours en
prison
j'espère que justice va passer très vite
je regrette qu'il a fait 15 ans pour
l'arrêter cela étant la serbie est en
train effectivement de tout faire tout
mettre en oeuvre de revoir ses lois et
de prendre des décisions vis-à-vis des
criminels de guerre qu'on attendait donc
la porte s'ouvre pour qu'il puisse un
jour intégrer l'europe oui merci c'est
parce que nous allons nous quitter on ne
retrouve pas la semaine prochaine mais
la semaine suivante pour un nouveau
numéro de parlement et doit revoir et
merci